ich habe der frau berbalk gar nicht
geschadet ich glaube ich habe geholfen
ich habe die entscheidung erleichtert
möglichst schnell zurück zu treten das
feld zu räumen
es kann ja nicht sein dass in
deutschland allen ernstes jemand für die
kanzlerschaft kandidiert bei dem ich
mich fragen muss hat diese person
überhaupt so etwas wie eigene ideen kann
diese person überhaupt selbst
formulieren wenn sie nicht ein internet
ein internet libretto vor sich liegen
hat von dem sie ab schreibt sondern
überhaupt mit ihnen eine eine wirklich
objektive diskussion führen wenn aus
ihnen so offensichtlich eine vorgefasste
subjektive schon sentierte meinung über
wissenschaftliche arbeiten als ich auf
einen einzigen kandidaten jetzt best buy
belassen
die normen oder dass man sie gerne
machen aber ich möchte gern hier mit
feststellen wir haben wichtige probleme
als in einem bei 1 buchst
ich meine es so dass ein paar fußnoten
darum geht's bei mir sie haben das
problem nicht verstanden dass müller den
druck bei vorbereiten
malek steht ihnen hier trafen sie das
ist lästig nicht zum nächsten laufen
lassen sich kurze werden und deswegen
jetzt schon wichtig wenn wir mal wird
nicht hinhalten über wichtige dinge
reden also ich glaube wir haben in den
vergangenen tagen sehr viel über die
reine verrutschen der werte gesprochen
und über eine verlagerung das fachthemen
mir wurde eine ent sachlichen
vorgeworfen dann muss ich sagen ich
möchte jetzt ernstlich dieses thema in
den mittelpunkt rücken
was hier passiert ist und man kann er
hier nicht davon reden dass ein buch
geschrieben wurde
das wurde mittels copy base
zusammengestoppelt so dass man es
eigentlich jedem schüler jeden 16
jährigen zurück schmeißen würde aber er
geht es darum dass jemand copy paste
dann statt dass er selber schreibt
verstehe und ich sage es nochmal das
gegen zu orthodox ja wie von der kanzel
gepredigt wir haben in unserer kultur
seit 1730 im buchdruck die idee dass ein
buch auf dem annalena baerbock oben
steht von der annalena baerbock stammen
von mir das noch von diesem herrn meier
passagenweise wenn sie sich die meisten
politischen bücher von spitzenpolitikern
anschauen die sind das sind lauter
solche koproduktionen
da kommt das meiste was geschrieben
wurde genau von diesen co-autoren das
ist aber entstanden in gesprächen mit
den jeweiligen politikern und politik
haben das geht über alle parteien hinweg
also da würde ich jetzt auch um er nicht
fakten aber entscheiden weil diese
gerade hatten also schlimmer war seit
der gesellschaftliche arbeit mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schaue ich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren